Alright, so let's get into the OSI model and what we're going to do at this point is we're
going to start. Alright, so let's get into the OSI model and what we're going to do at this
point is we're going to start with layer number one which is the physical layer as you know and we're
going to talk about some important things about each of the layers as we start going up. For example,
we're going to talk about what the layer actually does, some of the significant risks and security
that needs to be applied at each of these layers but also significant devices and protocols that
operate at each of the layers. So we're going to do this for physical layer, layer number one and
then we'll do the same for layer number two, the data link layer and then we'll do the same for
layer number three, the network layer and go all the way up to layer number seven, the application
layer. But let's start with layer number one and we've already talked about what this does but
the physical layer is what connects devices together. Obviously a network has to be a whole bunch of
devices that are connected to each other. How we connect those devices together is what's happening
at the physical layer. So the physical layer uses really two ways to connect devices together. If
you think about this makes logical sense we can connect devices together using wired technologies
or wireless technologies and we're going to talk about wireless later on in this course but for now
let's focus on the three different types of media that we can use to connect the physical
layer or devices together using the physical layer and that is of course twisted pair coaxial
and fiber optic technologies. Now one of the questions that they may ask you in regards to this
on the exam is which of these would you choose but what's important for us to understand
is the advantages and disadvantages that each of these provide but from a security perspective.
So if you look at the three types of wired technologies that we can use you know a lot of people
would say well let's use fiber optic but you would not say it's fiber optic because of speed. In fact
there is no limitation in how we can send voltage across twisted pair and coaxial
as well like we could probably the limitation would be speed of light as well as light that
fiber optic uses. So on the exam questions you really need to focus on what it's asking you
and that is the security advantage and some of these have better advantages than others. Now
if you remember to what the physical layer actually does the only thing it can do because that's
where we are the least intelligent layer one is the least intelligent but it's the most efficient
it's the fastest. All it knows how to do is represent the zeros and the ones using the technology
that it understands. So for using twisted pair we're sending voltage across the line in order to
represent the zeros and the ones and in fact a one is plus five volts a zero is minus five volts
that's what we send across the line to represent the bits the zeros and the ones. Now they might
ask you why we twist I mean twisted pair means exactly that. We've got two wires that are actually
twisted a certain way and the reason we do that is if you twist a certain way creates a magnetic
field that keeps the signal within that magnetic field. So it gives us some added protection against
crosstalk noise interference and then you'll probably know this you know there's different types
of twisted pair shielded and unshielded. What would be better obviously shielded because it gives
us protection as well. Now the next media that you see there is coaxial and I think you can picture
what this looks like because it's typically used by your cable companies to deliver television
signals into your house but really what's delivering those signals and that information is that little
copper wire that's in the middle of that coaxial cable and if you look at that coaxial cable it
actually has shielding and some other things built in to try and protect the quality and the
integrity of that signal that's going across that little copper wire and the only disadvantage
of using coaxial is what they say it's expensive and it may be stiffer to use for certain types
of applications. The preferred media to use today is fiber optic not only does it give us enhancements
in integrity but there are some added capabilities from a security perspective because it's harder
to tap into and it gives us more protection against noise and interference and crosstalk so those
are the types of questions that they may ask you which of these would be best to use from a
security perspective and your choice would be fiber optic and here's a definition of what crosstalk
is which could be one of those issues that you need to address always in whatever wire media we
are using to connect devices together. So it's a signal that bleeds into another basically so that's
why shielding and some of those protection mechanisms are required so we want to limit
what crosstalk impacts the quality of that transmission. So if you see a question like this one
crosstalk is least of an issue with which media the obvious answer to this would be fiber optic
cabling and that's why we would choose that from a security perspective.